selection is there to break you they
don't want you they don't want it they
don't want nothing to do with it the
first four weeks is called aptitude as
far as the the SAS is concerned we call
it the tree other Hills all right is the
hills face it's basically a series of
walking over the hills with a pack that
goes larger and larger with a distance
that gets further and further you know
you do exactly what you're told when
you're told how you're told and you just
walk the hills and that's it and it's
designed in four weeks you know if you
really don't want to be there you
probably would have would have handed
yourself in by now do you know what I
mean because you know if you don't want
to be there you won't stay because it's
one of those things it will break you'll
break you eventually uh also it will
find that if you're robust enough you
know I had toenails missing I had skin
off the back you know I had blisters on
my feet I had a dislodged retina I had
all sorts wrong with my body but I ended
up four weeks you know I had plenty of
excuse to say I'll say what I've had
enough do you know me